Transcriptor: Kevin Álvarez
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Las emociones han existido siempre?
En todos los lugares
y en todas las épocas
el ser humano ha tendido a interpretar
sus experiencias según lo que sentía,
pero no siempre hemos sentido lo mismo,
y tampoco siempre lo hemos llamado
con las mismas palabras.
Llevo 20 años trabajando
sobre la historia de las emociones,
una disciplina que es relativamente nueva,
desde la que intentamos replantearnos
lo que son las emociones
y evitar las versiones simplificadas.
Partimos de tres premisas.
La primera es que las emociones no son
solo la cara que ponemos al expresarlas,
como parece que piensan Paul Ekman
y sus seguidores en EE.UU.
La segunda es que las emociones
las vivimos a través del lenguaje
los nombres que les damos
y las palabras con que las expresamos
son esenciales para entenderlas.
Y la tercera es que esas palabras
tienen una larga historia
en la que han cambiado de significado.
Voy a ilustrar tres aspectos
de mi trabajo sobre las emociones
con ejemplos extraídos
de documentos históricos.
El primer aspecto es el poder
de la imaginación sobre las emociones.
Solo con pensar en algo que podría ocurrir
la imaginación nos hace sentir emociones.
Propongo que ejercitemos nuestra empatía
para pasar a momentos históricos
empezando con principios del siglo XV.
El momento en que los navegadores
portugueses partían con miedo,
intentando bordear la costa de África,
sin saber si iban a conseguir llegar
más allá que sus predecesores
y sin saber si iban a poder regresar.
Lo que les llevaba a superar el miedo
y embarcarse era la esperanza.
La esperanza de conseguir
beneficios económicos.
En aquel momento de ausencias
el rey D. Duarte, de Portugal
escribió sobre lo que entonces
se denominaba soydade.
La definía como algo que sentimos
con el corazón en dos tipos de situación.
Una es al estar alejados
de la persona a quién tenemos gran afecto,
y la otra, antes de que eso ocurra,
cuando sabemos
que esa separación es inminente.
El rey también distinguía
entre la saudade como recuerdo
de un pasado que disfrutamos mucho
y la que sentimos simplemente al pensar
en lo que nos gustaría que ocurriera.
Esta última idea es bastante parecida
a lo que podríamos llamar falsa nostalgia,
que a veces nos creamos
a nosotros mismos soñando despiertos.
El rey también hizo una distinción entre
la saudade triste y la saudade placentera.
La triste es cuando el recuerdo
nos hace desear echar marcha atrás
y estar en aquella conversación
con ese amigo que ahora ya no está.
Y la placentera es cuando
en lugar de sufrir por esa ausencia
disfrutamos de los recuerdos
del tiempo pasado.
Pasamos a otro momento histórico.
Finales del siglo XVII, momento en
el que se inventa la palabra nostalgia.
Era 1688, un suizo que estudiaba
Medicina en la Universidad de Basilea
llamado Johannes Hofer hizo su tesis
sobre un fenómeno que observó
entre gente que vivía alejada de su país.
Algunos, el estar lejos de su tierra
les hacía entristecerse y languidecían
enfermaban y no se recuperaban.
Este fenómeno ya tenía nombre en alemán,
se llamaba "Heimweh",
en francés se llamaba "mal du pays".
Lo que ocurre es que estos términos
no resultaban convincentes
como categoría nosológica
para hacer diagnósticos.
Se necesitaba un término técnico.
A Hofer se le ocurrió
combinar dos palabras griegas.
"nostos", que significa vuelta a casa
y "algia", de algos, que significa dolor.
Entre los casos
que incluyó Hofer en su tesis
encontramos a un suizo que emigró a París
y una vez allí echaba tanto de menos
las montañas suizas
que enfermó al querer verlas otra vez
y no poder hacerlo.
Entonces, en el momento en que el señor
para el que trabajaba
le concedió permiso para viajar
empezó a recuperarse,
se recuperó del todo y al final ni viajó.
Lo cuento como ejemplo de
cómo el pensar que algo es posible
ya nos hace cambiar la forma de sentir
y también para que nos planteemos
si en nuestra cultura valoramos
lo suficiente el poder de la imaginación.
Además, este ejemplo me lleva
al segundo aspecto
que quiero dar a conocer
con mi trabajo sobre las emociones
y es que la relación de mente,
cuerpo y emociones que se entendió
desde la medicina hipocrática
desde hace 25 siglos
y se empezó a olvidar como
a mediados del siglo XIX
está empezando a recordarse,
es algo que está ahí.
Y las emociones influyen sobre
nuestra salud física y mental
y lo que hacemos con el cuerpo:
lo que dormimos, lo que comemos,
y cuanto,
y si hacemos mucho ejercicio,
llevamos una vida muy sedentaria,
tiene un claro efecto
sobre lo que sentimos.
Vamos a verlo en el contexto de 1792.
Habían pasado tres años
desde la Revolución Francesa
y se iniciaba una guerra
que duraría 23 años.
Las guerras revolucionarias
y napoleónicas.
Durante ese momento
de la historia de Francia
la nostalgia se convirtió
en algo epidémico.
Fue la mayor causa de suicidios
y se escribieron numerosos tratados
y artículos sobre el tema.
Habiendo leído unos cuantos
voy a descifrar lo que me parece
que son cuatro factores.
Uno es que muchos de los soldados
que aparecían en los hospitales
en estado nostálgico o muy enfermos
habían sufrido heridas
estaban débiles y malnutridos,
y esa debilidad les hacía sentirse tristes
y querer volver a casa.
El otro factor es que muchos de ellos
luchaban obligados por unos ideales
en los que a veces ni siquiera creían,
era una nación francesa nueva,
una república que a veces no entendían.
El tercer factor es que en aquel momento
de la historia de Francia
un tercio de la población francesa
no hablaba francés como lengua madre.
Hablaba bretón, alemán, vasco o catalán.
El hecho de que muchos de esos soldados
hablaran dialectos o lenguas
que otros no hablaban contribuía
a lo que yo veo como cuarto factor,
el aislamiento, la soledad
y la incomunicación.
Voy a dar un ejemplo
que explica estos factores.
En 1792 hubo un cirujano
llamado Moreau de Lasarte
que curó a un soldado nostálgico,
pidiendo a otro soldado de su región
que tuviera conversaciones con él
en las que fueran rememorando vivencias
con esto consiguió curarle,
el soldado recuperó
las ganas de vivir y seguir luchando.
Parece ser que el salir de la soledad
con las conversaciones
y con las rememoraciones de sus vivencias
del pasado fue la mejor terapia.
No todos los médicos pensaban que
la nostalgia era una enfermedad aparte.
Muchos pensaban que era
simplemente un tipo de melancolía.
La melancolía desde antiguo se entendía
como algo que afectaba a mente y cuerpo,
y que estaba asociado
con el miedo y la tristeza.
Desde finales de la primera guerra mundial
nadie se ha muerto ni de nostalgia,
ni de melancolía.
Estos términos
han cambiado de significado.
Como vemos algunas emociones similares
tienen nombres y matices distintos
según su relación con el tiempo
y con el espacio.
En cada época y lugar conforme cambian
las circunstancias y las sensibilidades
se han encontrado síntomas diferentes
asociados a emociones
y se han encontrado también
formas de manejarlas y terapias diferentes
Por ejemplo, la nostalgia antigua,
la saudade, tiene en común
la sensación de soledad
y estas dos tienen en común con la
melancolía el sentimiento de ausencia,
que a veces lleva al ensimismamiento.
La melancolía ya empezó a cambiar
a manos del psicoanálisis
cuando le dieron un significado parecido
a lo que hoy entendemos como depresión.
En 1917, Freud escribió
y publicó un tratado
en el que hacía una distinción
entre el duelo como tristeza
ante una pérdida de algo
o alguien importante
y la melancolía como una tristeza
de más larga duración
que no tenía causas evidentes.
Siete décadas más tarde la psicoanalista
y linguista Julia Kristeva
retomó esa distinción y añadió
que a veces ante situaciones de pérdida
real o sentida nos aferramos a la tristeza
como si esta pudiera suplir
aquello que sentimos
que hemos perdido.
Además, ella sugería una alternativa
al uso de fármacos antidepresivos,
el conectar con imágenes
artísticas y con poemas.
Según Kristeva aquellos que tienen
demasiada tristeza
son incapaces de encontrar
el sentido al lenguaje lógico
y sin embargo el lenguaje poético
con sus ritmos, aliteraciones y rimas
puede hacer enganchar al que está triste
y hacerle procesar y superar
o transformar esa tristeza.
Desde mi punto de vista
el escuchar música o escuchar poemas
en lenguaje poético y sus ritmos
nos puede ayudar a entender
que las emociones no es algo
que llevamos dentro y que expresamos,
sino algo que nos ayuda
a conectar con otros.
Propongo un experimento.
Que escuchemos parte de un poema
de Rosalía de Castro, de 1884,
en el que se alude a la saudade
de la mujer del emigrante
que está a punto de partir,
y también se evocan otras emociones
que ayudan a contrarrestar esa tristeza.
(Recitando)
Era la última noche,
la noche de las tristes despedidas,
y apenas si una lágrima empañaba
sus serenas pupilas.
Como el criado que deja
al amo que le hostiga,
arreglando su hatillo, murmuraba
casi con la emoción de la alegría:
¡Llorar! ¿Por qué? Fortuna es que podamos
abandonar nuestras humildes tierras,
el duro pan que nos negó la patria,
por más que los extraños nos maltraten,
no ha de faltarnos en la patria ajena.
Y los hijos contentos se sonríen,
y la esposa, aunque triste, se consuela
con la firme esperanza
de que el que parte ha de volver por ella.
Pensar que han de partir, ese es el sueño
que da fuerza en su angustia
a los que quedan.
Con este poema quería ilustrar
el tercer aspecto
de mi trabajo sobre las emociones.
Las estudio en su contexto
histórico y sociocultural
y en situaciones específicas
en las que la interacción social
da forma y transforma
las emociones de unos y de otros
y eso no se puede recrear
en ningún laboratorio.
En cuanto al poder de la palabra,
quería señalar que existe algo
llamado biblioterapia
que por ejemplo en el Reino Unido,
hay gente que va a los hospitales
a leer poemas de Shakespeare a enfermos,
porque aunque no tengan ya capacidad
de usar el lenguaje
son capaces de sentir
el ritmo de las palabras,
de la palabra poética, la palabra hablada.
En Estados Unidos, por ejemplo,
hay gente que se dedica
a leer historias de pérdida
a niños que han perdido a sus padres
para que al compartir ese trauma
puedan procesar su tristeza
y puedan sentirse un poco menos solos.
Termino volviendo al ahora, a una
situación específica de este momento.
¿Qué hacemos cuando escuchamos
que en la frontera
de Estados Unidos con México
se han estado separando
a niños emigrantes de sus padres?
Cómo respondemos al leer informes
sobre las reacciones de tristeza, miedo,
angustia e ira de estos niños y
los problemas mentales que están teniendo
y al saber que entre mayo y junio de 2018
se recetaron fármacos antidepresivos
a 300 de estos niños.
Cómo nos sentimos al ver
a esos otros niños migrantes,
cruzar el Mediterráneo jugándose la vida,
con la esperanza de mejorarla
para terminar encontrándose aquí
con la soledad y el aislamiento.
Quizá respondamos
con tristeza o con rabia,
o quizá esta situación
nos ayude a cultivar la compasión.
La compasión no es una de esas emociones
que se sienten sin querer,
va más allá de la empatía
y de la sensibilidad.
No consiste en imaginarse
la tristeza de otro y tenerle lástima
para que así ese otro se sienta
menos solo si sufrimos con él.
La compasión se aprende, se cultiva,
saliendo del ensimismamiento,
no dejándonos cegar por nuestras emociones
o por las de otros
y utilizando la inteligencia
para contener los pensamientos
negativos y dolorosos
y centrarnos en buscar
soluciones conjuntas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)